-And finally, guys,
I want to give a shout-out
to Rock & Roll Hall of Famer
John Fogerty,
who just kicked off his new
Celebration Tour this week.
We love John Fogerty.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John stopped by the show
earlier today,
so we stepped into
the "Tonight Show" music room
with The Roots, we grabbed
some classroom instruments
and did our own version of the
Creedence Clearwater Revival hit
"Lookin' Out My Back Door."
Check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo beat plays ]
[ Kazoo playing ]
♪♪
-♪ Just got home from Illinois ♪
♪ Lock the front door, oh, boy ♪
♪ Got to sit down,
take a rest on the porch ♪
♪ Imagination sets in ♪
♪ Pretty soon I'm singin' ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo,
lookin' out my back door ♪
-♪ There's a giant
doin' cartwheels ♪
♪ A statue wearin' high heels ♪
♪ Look at all
the happy creatures ♪
♪ Dancin' on the lawn ♪
♪ A dinosaur Victrola ♪
♪ Listenin' to Buck Owens ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo,
lookin' out my back door ♪
-♪ Well, tambourines
and elephants ♪
♪ Are playin' in the band ♪
♪ Won't you take a ride
on the flyin' spoon? ♪
♪ Doo-doo-doo ♪
♪ Wondrous apparition ♪
♪ Provided by magician ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo,
lookin' out my back door ♪
-Take it.
♪♪
♪ Forward troubles Illinois ♪
♪ Lock the front door, oh, boy ♪
♪ Look at all the happy
creatures ♪
♪ Dancin' on the lawn ♪
♪ Bother me tomorrow ♪
♪ Today I'll buy no sorrow ♪
-♪ Doo, doo, doo,
lookin' out my back door ♪
-Yeah.
♪ Doo, doo, doo,
lookin' out my back door ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey!
-Hey.
-My thanks Shane, Tyler,
and John Fogerty.